THANK YOU.
>> Bill: WE’LL TALK ABOUT NEXT
WEEK.
BACK TO THE LATEST CDC GUIDANCE.
AGENCY SAYING THOSE FULLY
VACCINATED DON’T NEED TO WEAR A
MASK OR PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING BUT STILL URGING
PEOPLE ON THE SCREEN TO MASK UP
IN CROWDED INDOOR SPACES LIKE
PUBLIC TRANSIT OR COVID
SYMPTOMS.
DR. MARTY MAKARY, PROFESSOR AT
JOHNS HOPKINS.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
HELP TAKE US THROUGH THIS.
WHAT SHOULD WE UNDERSTAND ABOUT
IT NOW?
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO SIMPLIFY
GUIDANCE BY SIMPLY SAYING IF
YOU’VE BEEN FULLY VACCINATED
LIVE A NORMAL LIFE WITHOUT ANY
RESTRICTIONS EXCEPT IN
TRANSPORTATION SETTINGS.
THIS COMES IN THE CONTEXT OF A
LOT OF COMPLICATED RESTRICTIONS
STILL IN PLACE.
UNVAC NAILTED PEOPLE ARE STILL
TOLD TO WEAR MASKS OUTDOORS BY
THE CDC.
THAT MAKES NO SENSE.
THE CAMP GUIDANCE MAKES NO
SENSE FOR SUMMER CAMPS AND KIDS
ARE STILL SHUT OUT OF SCHOOLS.
THIS IS ONE BABY STEP AND COMES
ABOUT THREE MONTHS LATE.
>> Bill: THE CAMP GUIDANCE IF
YOU ARE A KID PLAYING SOCCER IN
JULY YOU HAVE TO WEAR A MASK.
I DON’T GET IT.
I MENTION THIS QUOTE FROM THE
CDC DIRECT FOR MARCH 29th ABOUT
IMPENDING DOOM.
>> REFLECT ON THE RECURRING
FEELING I HAVE OF IMPENDING
DOOM.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO LOOK FORWARD
TO, SO MUCH PROMISE AND
POTENTIAL OF WHERE WE ARE AND
SO MUCH REASON FOR HOPE BUT
RIGHT NOW I’M SCARED.
>> Bill: SHE SAID IT.
WHAT CHANGED?
>> WELL LOOK, THE NUMBERS ARE
WAY DOWN.
PLUMMETED.
THE REASON WE GOT THIS
ANNOUNCEMENT FROM THE CDC
YESTERDAY ALL OF A SUDDEN OUT
OF THE BLUE WITHOUT ANY SORT OF
WARNING WAS THAT CASES ARE DOWN
SO MUCH MORE THAN THE CDC
ANTICIPATED BECAUSE THEY’VE
BEEN IGNORING NATURAL
IMMUNITY’S CONTRIBUTION TO
POPULATION IMMUNITY.
THAT’S WHY WE GOT THIS SUDDEN
REACTION YESTERDAY.
>> Bill: OKAY.
HERE IS RANDY WEINGARTEN.
HEAD OF ONE OF THE LARGEST
TEACHERS UNIONS IN AMERICA.
SHE HAS BEEN RESISTANT FOR
MONTHS.
SHE CHANGED HER MIND YESTERDAY,
TOO.
WATCH.
>> CONDITIONS HAVE CHANGED.
WE CAN AND WE MUST REOPEN
SCHOOLS IN THE FALL FOR
IN-PERSON TEACHING, LEARNING,
AND SUPPORT.
AND WE MUST KEEP THEM OPEN,
FULLY AND SAFELY FIVE DAYS A
WEEK.
>> Bill: I SAID IT EARLIER.
LIKE FLIPPING A SWITCH, DOCTOR.
>> I THINK A LOT OF THIS IS
RHETORIC BECAUSE IT’S A HOPE.
IT’S WHAT THEY ASPIRE TO.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO IT THEY
SAID THAT ALL ALONG.
THEY SAID WE’VE HOPED AND OUR
PLAN HAS BEEN TO HAVE IN-PERSON
LEARNING.
WHAT THEY’VE BEEN ABLE TO DO IS
POSTPONE CDC GUIDANCE LONG
ENOUGH SO THE POLICY CAN
OUTLIVE THE REALITY AND THAT’S
WHAT HAS HAPPENED UNFORTUNATELY.
THE CONDITIONS MAY HAVE CHANGED
IN TERMS OF THE CASE NUMBERS,
THE SCIENCE HASN’T CHANGED.
IT WAS TRUE IN SEPTEMBER 2020
REPORT BY THE CDC SHOWING THAT
SCHOOLS WERE SAFE.
A LOT OF THIS DATA BOTH ON THE
LIFTING MASKS AMONG FULLY
VACCINATED ON SCHOOLS WAS FROM
THE ISRAELI STUDY DONE IN
FEBRUARY.
>> Bill: YOU ARE COOL WITH ALL
THIS, RIGHT?
YOU’RE GOOD?
>> LOOK, IT’S A BABY STEP
FORWARD AND I’M GOOD WITH IT.